the news came in a late night tweet from
the White House president Donald Trump
wrote tonight the first lady and I
tested positive for Co 19 we will begin
our quarantine and recovery process
immediately we will get through this
together it is not known how despite
elaborate precautions and constant
testing of White House officials the
White House Press Corps and others in
contact with Trump the president
contracted the
virus but earlier one of Trump's top
AIDS hope Hicks was confirmed to have
tested positive Hicks accompanied the
president to the debate in Cleveland
Ohio on Tuesday Trump phoned into a Fox
television program earlier on Thursday
and talked about Hicks having been
exposed it's a tough kind of a situation
it's a terrible thing so I just went for
a test and we'll see what happens I mean
who knows the White House physician Shan
Conley said Trump and the first lady are
both well at this time and that the
White House medical team will maintain a
Vigilant watch Melania Trump later
tweeted we are feeling good Trump has
several risk factors that put him in
danger of complications from Co 19 he is
in his mid 70s and overweight we have to
wait for the next few days uh and and um
you know for the uh some people get
really sick within hours but you know
some people don't get sick until week
after and so we have to really uh be
carefully observing the situation Trump
has declined to wear a mask on many
occasions including at rallies where
many of his supporters also refused to
wear a
mask his Entourage including family
members went maskless at the Tuesday
debate Trump even ridiculed Democratic
candidate Joe Biden for wearing a mask
mask as recommended by virtually all
public health experts I don't wear masks
like him every time you see him he's got
a mask he could be speaking 200 feet
away from it he shows up with the
biggest mask I've ever seen if Trump
were to become seriously ill and unable
to carry out his duties the Constitution
provides for vice president Mike Pence
to take over temporarily Pence said he
is praying for Trump's recovery there
can be no spin there can be no coverups
there has to be clear understanding of
what is going on with this person this
President of the United States because
otherwise if he is not capacitated to
take care of the business he will have
to be by the 25th Amendment uh you know
transition has to occur Detroit but a
glaring question now is how the news
will affect Trump's reelection campaign
already trailing nationally and in
certain important swing States it would
seem that Trump can ill afford to stay
out of commission for a quarantine
period of two weeks Trump joins other
world leaders including Brazil's
president Jer balcaro and the UK prime
minister Boris Johnson who have
contracted the virus worldwide the death
toll from coid 19 has exceeded 1 million
Rob Reynolds Al jazer